well a storm system that brought major
flooding to the Midwest will impact tens
of millions of people on the East Coast
this morning it already dumped several
inches of rain from Missouri to Ohio in
Wisconsin the fox river crested
yesterday at a record level rivers are
still rising in Illinois and Ohio
David big Noah is in Finley Ohio where
the Blanchard River is already above
major flood stage David good morning
good morning from flag city USA that's
what Findlay Ohio calls itself I'm
standing in the Blanchard River that's
because it's overtopped its bank and as
far as you could see just look it's
probably spread 300 yards the river went
from below flood stage two above major
flood stage in four hours this is Main
Street and look at all the water but as
fast as the water rose weather experts
say it could be gone by Saturday night a
new wave of thunderstorms tore through
the Midwest overnight the torrential
rain was relentless and areas already
covered in water a view from above
central Ohio shows the widespread damage
there a carnival a high school football
field and several homes were immersed
under inches of water they just wouldn't
stop you know you just keep saying on
please just one person had to be rescued
after rushing water swept their vehicle
away in nearby Hebron the heavy rain
forced dozens of people to evacuate this
mobile home park first responders used
boats to get them out it's flooded
before but nothing this severe this is
totally incredible and in Finley several
city streets are closed because of high
water some cars were left stranded
to the northwest in Wisconsin the Fox
River reached record levels cresting at
more than 17 feet that is 2 feet above
the highest level recorded House Speaker
Paul Ryan returned to his home state to
tour the areas devastated by the storm
this happened so fast it really really
happened so fast that so many people
were caught off guard so it's a real
blessing that we did not have the kind
of loss of life or injury that could
have happened for some people in
Lincolnshire just north of Chicago
paddling was about the only way home
we're gonna pray that this is it this as
high as it goes nobody else needs more
water it's done enough damage
back here in Fendley Ohio I noticed the
window was open on the second story of a
building here in downtown that was
surrounded in water and I yelled for the
person to see if they were okay and the
guy said yeah I'm fine his name was
Robert he said I'm headed to work and
sure enough a few minutes later the door
open and here came Robert with his bike
over his shoulder Nora he said I work in
the plastics business and he said nobody
pays my bills come hell or high water he
said I'm on my way to work
there you go that's right people got to
get to work David beg no as always thank
you so much